so if you have trouble consuming nuts this
video is for you whether you're consuming
almonds pecans brazil nuts so a lot of people
get this bloating and they're not sure why well
nuts have more phytic acid than even grains or
legumes but what is this thing called phytic acid
phytic acid is something that a seed uses to help
bind minerals and prevent biochemical reactions
to allow this seed to sprout so phytic acid is
kind of a chemical to keep things locked up and
when you consume seeds with phytic acid you are
not only creating a problem in the absorption
of calcium iron magnesium zinc copper but also
because some of those minerals are used in enzymes
overall when you consume nuts you can't utilize
a lot of these enzymes to help you digest them
so it's a situation where you're consuming a
food without the enzymes and so it tends to sit
in the stomach create all sorts of bloating
create irritation and even inflammation
so the worst nut that has the highest phytic
acid is almonds it is 9.4 percent phytic acid
walnuts are six point seven percent phytic acid
and brazil nuts are six point three percent now if
you compare these two grains grains are actually
a lot less but there's a very simple solution
to phytic acid all you have to do is mimic the
normal sprouting process or germination process
that naturally occurs when you plant a seed and
to do that you just soak them in water overnight
that will start the process going
the phytic acid will be released
this whole binding process between minerals will
go away so you can actually absorb these minerals
and now this nut is going to be much easier
to digest now the problem is you can have
this silky soggy wet nut so you're gonna have
to dry it out and the best way to do that is
either put it in the oven at a very low
temperature or a dehydrator for a period of time
until it's dry but what you're going to find is
when you germinate nuts and seeds and dry them out
the taste is much better the nutrition is way way
better and they're just much easier to digest so
if you're enjoying my content which i hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i'd really appreciate you
sharing your success story so click the link down
below to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others